well good evening
uh members and officers who've joined us
for this evening's
meeting of the overview and scrutiny
panel
i'll just run through the the
housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated
please vacate these offices down the
main staircase opposite the left in the
foyer
assemble in holy square on the green and
officers will assist us and advise us
when it's deemed safe
to return to the chamber with everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
david lean has just left
since there is no one attempting to film
the meeting i will skip over the parts
about filming um
speaking under rule 20.1 i haven't
received any requests at the moment to
speak under rule
20.1
i can't see any guest members here
either
i have also not received any requests
for public speaking
so we move on to our agenda proper and
the election
of a vice chair you are all aware that
last time we met there was a
slight hiccup that was discovered after
the election
had taken place so we need to run that
election again can i please have
nominations
for the vacant post of vice chair
of this committee councilor key
thank you i'd like to nominate
councillor alan curry
[Music]
and do we have a second for that please
counselor pat moore i'd like to second
that
any other nominations council ratigan
councillor phil fellows
and do we have a second though i'd like
to second that chair
councillor paul more
anymore
in the order in which the members were
suggested then can i ask for a show of
hands
for those in favor of councillor alan
curry
please one two three
and those in favor of counsellor
phil fellows please
from the floor with the vote of six to
five councillor fellows
is voted as vice chair of this committee
thank you very much
council of fellows for being prepared to
sit as vice chair of this committee can
i
just ask you to come and get this for me
there is no name on it it simply says
vice chair
what i would like to do is to be in the
habit
of giving you as vice chair the script
for each meeting as we go along in
advance of the meetings so you know
exactly
what is coming for the meetings and just
in case
something would happen and you would
need to take
the meeting instead
thank you very much members uh agenda i
think
number two then the next generation is
apologies for absence uh councillor
linda piper
is away in wales i'm afraid with her
sisters
sorting out her late mother's home
so she does send her apologies are there
any other apologies i don't think so
because i can count 12
bodies in the seats
are there any decorations of interest
for the business at hand this evening
[Music]
the next agenda item is to approve the
minutes
of the overview and scrutiny panel
meeting um
didn't we do that at the last one it's
the 8th of july
okay all right thank you very much
just checking the dates the minutes of
the last time
regular scheduled meeting of this
committee
can i have a proposal
council fellows thank you and
i'll second that from the chair and
members happy to
accept those minutes thank you very much
our next agenda item is the planning
enforcement review
a report back from the planning
enforcement
working party uh councillor paul moore
has been chairing that
uh enforcement working party so uh paul
if i can hand over to you please
uh thank you chair um everyone should
have received the supplementary agenda
in that pack and the following
recommendations were made and i'll read
them out to you
investigations be carried out to
determine the potential utility of a
planning enforcement portal
on the council's website to provide
updates to members
of the public and elected members of the
current cases as well as an increasing
increasing availability of information
about the enforcement process for the
public
a review to conduct to be conducted to
identify how the council could come up
with more effective system
of prioritizing planning enforcement
cases a review to be conducted to
determine how best to improve
communication between the council
and the complainants regarding planning
enforcement cases being handled by the
council
and lastly investigations be carried out
to determine how best the council could
include proactive work
in the planning enforcement protocol
if i can just go to the agenda
chair the the options are that the panel
is being asked to consider
to either adopt the working party's
recommendations highlighted in the
paragraph
3.2 points one to four which i've just
read out
or members may opt to reject all or some
of the recommendations in which case
guidance
on a way forward would be sought from
the panel thank you chair
thank you very much councillor moore
members comments please
counselor huxley thanks chair
i'm sorry i couldn't come to that
meeting i wanted to but i was on holiday
and uh councillor whitehead i think uh
uh substituted for me um i
support all the proposals that you put
forward and you discussed
i think a really good idea um i was a
bit disappointed about not
increasing the staffing levels that was
something that ian livingston put in his
uh original report i think that's a
really shame
that's not going to happen i mean some
because of financial
uh issues how about thinking outside the
box
uh you could second member staff from
tdc planning to do that
to to spend some of their time
doing um planning enforcement you could
adopt an apprentice
they have done that in the housing
department we talked about that last
time
why can't we do that they've got three
there there's government apprentice
scheme
money available i think still from
central government
um david district council has four
planning enforcement officers and one
assistant
and we only have one and one assistant
so you know
they're a similar cancer to us they have
similar problems they have similar
financial difficulties and also
for in what's the proposal what's the
timeline for this does this come to full
council do we talk about it a bit more
what do we do thanks
thank you very much mr livingston please
thank you chair um so to just come back
on the point with regards to
resources the recommendations of the
working group
were to sort of add a bit more meat to
the review
so the review itself was outlined in the
report originally they went before
osp or in february and that does include
at the end of the process of reviewing
the way enforcement works and also the
systems we use
we would be looking at additional
resources
and considering that obviously that is
always going to be
you know a large part of that
consideration it's gonna be about you
know the availability and finances
available
um options including um apprentices is
something indeed that we have looked at
in the past and we will continue to look
at into the future we do
involve planning officers in planning
enforcement um in
writing notices and also visiting sites
and assisting with that so that's
covered by by the existing work um but
in terms of the the second point about
time scale and what's what's now sort of
going to happen
the review itself will be occurring over
the next six months the aim is to finish
it by the end of the year
what we would also look to do is update
the planning enforcement protocol
that protocol has to go to planning
committee
first of all to be adopted and then to
full council to get that adopted
so some of these recommendations that
were made at the working group would be
integrated into that protocol
and if if the chair would allow it i
would suggest that
it would be worth um coming back before
the end of the year to osp
with a report showing how we've
integrated the working group
um your recommendations into the review
and then giving a summary of what came
out of that review
thank you
thank you very much i'm just having a
look at our
calendar of events moving forward the
latest opportunity we would have
for a regular uh scheduled meeting
members would be the meeting
shadowed for the 23rd of november
i mean is that sort of date going to be
too late
for your review before the end of the
year or is that the sort of time you had
in mind
it's good to have a deadline so yes i'll
go with i'll go with that
can i ask a question i feel the same way
as council huxley about the the staffing
can i ask a question about
what potential there is for generation
of income or generation of savings if
there were more staffing
involved on planning enforcement
is it okay to come back on that chair
yeah um so
one of the things we've actually talked
about in the working group was
um about sort of whether our planning
enforcement can
generate income that the council can use
to actually resource itself on that
particular service
it's um there are ways to do that
through um
the um proceeds of crime act but that
money gets shared out
uh amongst various different sort of
parties to that sort of work
um and that isn't something therefore
we've been able to really um take a good
opportunity
to come under and also it only applies
to very specific cases
um so there isn't really necessarily a
way of generating income through
enforcement that then
gives more resources but obviously the
aim would be to see
whether or not it's it's financially
possible
to you know create some additional
resource using
other income that potentially the
planning department gets in through for
example
planning fees and obviously if we are
through enforcement getting more
planning applications in that obviously
generates the fee income which then
allows for more case to be made to
finance to be able to fund an additional
officer
great thank you
thank you for the reports um councilman
moore
and ian um two questions
and i apologize a bit vague my
um modern gov seems to have come up with
a version two which wasn't the same
version as the one that was on at half
seven this morning so my notes have
disappeared
um the first question um just to link on
from
uh these two's points about the staffing
have you looked at perhaps monitoring
the productivity of the staffing levels
particularly now that we're moving to
perhaps flexible working
to see how they're coping with their
workload and could that build more of a
business case for a need for an
additional member of staff
and the second point and i apologize
because i'm not an expert on planning
but out of the recommendations do any of
that cover the proactive approach in
terms of
making it i think the report says
something about there's no incentive for
people to go through the planning
application because they could just
build whatever they want
and then get it in retrospect so how can
we address that issue to make it an
incentive do we increase the fees so
they don't bother doing that
but how do we stop them from just
building whatever they like and then
just it's okay because we can just pay
off the fees afterwards and get the
permission afterwards
and so to the to the first point um in
terms of productivity
it is something that's monitored on a
way on a weekly basis because we have a
weekly enforcement meeting with
both the officers and we run through the
cases that have arrived previous week
looking at the long-standing notices and
and that sort of works and that will
indeed be used to inform any additional
resource because it'll be about
determining
once going through the review and seeing
where the gaps are in the process all
the gaps are in terms of what the work
the council are doing on either
say high priority cases it's obviously
about identifying if additional
resources is going to be asked for what
level that comes in at because obviously
we have
you know an assistant level and an
officer level at the moment um
it's worth noting actually sorry
something i haven't also mentioned is
that there isn't
an added implication on planning
enforcement which is about legal support
um you know it does they do go hand in
hand because obviously if we are looking
to prosecute cases
we do need additional legal support to
do that so you know we are
looking to integrate any potential
additional resource with legal
and to work out how we can do that
because that's how we actually find
people and actually use
the teeth of the system um in terms of
the proactive point um a couple of
things that we discussed
one that we discussed the working group
in terms of productivity is the fact
that
there is no um there's no punitive
measure for someone to do
work without consent they are allowed to
apply retrospectively and this is
something that comes up a lot of
planning committee
and i appreciate a lot of members
concerns about this
in terms of creating an incentive for
planning there are a number of things
that we've done in the past so for
example
contacting estate agents getting sort of
integrated with them so that they know
that when a property comes up for sale
uh you know we monitor sites to see well
is this
you know for example does a change of
views happen and it's being sold as
three flats rather than two
um and obviously it usually planning
always comes into play when someone
wants to
sell a property and a search pulls up
something or you know that sort of thing
so it's about
trying things slightly outside the box
rather than the sort of idea of
simply responding to complaints that we
get in or what we've seen on the street
so it is about trying to harness the
information that we've got in um
but in terms of the actual system
unfortunately is the case that you know
people can carry works and apply
retrospectively
um and the incentive of of according
with the rules
is one that you've recorded the rules
but also so you've got that document
that if people want to
say sell properties that they're not
going to come a cropper basically on a
house cell and things like that
thank you
thank you members at the moment we're
talking about staffing is it still on
staffing or is it a new subject
uh counselor keane okay
thank you i just thought whilst ian's
talking about staffing if there were any
questions about
staffing if we
um probably a mile out in left field but
not the kind of work that could be
subcontracted on a case-by-case basis to
dover kind of shared resources
i don't think dover would be
particularly keen on that um
but i'd love to use one of their offices
um um
but i mean it's you know
we we do think those there's
opportunities to
utilize the resources that we've got
there is a lot of work that goes on
behind the scenes
between different enforcement parts of
the council
um you know the enforcement officer sits
on the empty properties group for
example obviously working with the
uh you know the housing team on that as
well as going out with task force so
it there is some work i think to be done
to maybe crystallize the those sort of
connections that have been made over a
number of years
to try and first of all use the
resources that we've got internally
and i mean i could speak to the dm
manager of dover but i think it would be
slightly trying it on thank you
thank you chair um my
my sort of question comment was one of
the things we get most of all from the
public
is when there's big developments and
then
in one of the terms is that they're
planting so many trees and have to look
after them for five years
but they don't or they are supposed to
provide
play areas by a certain stage in the
development
and they don't and how is that
enforced what kind of priority does that
currently get
would that change at all in the future
because i think with these big
developments we've got coming up
it's something we really need to get on
top of
okay yes this is an issue that has
get certainly gained in in prevalence as
more things actually being built out in
the last couple of years in the district
um you know we are a
it's the high priority cases are ones
that you know affect
um people's living conditions
conservation of conservation areas
listed buildings um and also tpo trees
those are the key ones that we would
look to first as high priority
but as part of the review one of the
things that we are doing is looking at
that sort of prioritization
matrix almost to see actually well what
what is generating the most complaints
and one of the things that has come up a
lot by
members is compliance with conditions
now we have got existing resource
within the planning team but not within
the enforcement team that we have a
dedicated planning assistant who looks
at condition submission details
and that does allow some oversight at
the point of which the details are
submitted and obviously we actually have
often people will start building on site
and then they're applying for their
conditions at that point so that we have
got the ability to either visit the site
or at least get more information in on
that
um but it is something that will be
certainly integrated into
the the protocol uh the enforcement
protocol
to look at the issue we have a
particular site at the moment which i
won't say on the record
where we are going to be serving breach
condition notices imminently
because they haven't complied with the
conditions on the development side it's
something that is coming up more and
more as
more development is happening thank you
now just to say chair oh no don't let's
go down the route of going
to try and have a joint services with
dover
because we did it with housing it was a
disaster thank you
um with the um the fees that you pay
for retrospective are they can the
council set their own
fees or is it standard fees set by the
government
um it's a standard fee set by the
government
there's been long long held ideas to
have
locally set fees but they've never come
to fruition i have no idea if that is
something that is planned in the future
but it's it's set by the government
thanks chad um yeah this question
section 106 money
and i said to you and
once that that section 106 money is
identified and put forward by
the developer how long would we expect
to wait
before that money is actually used um in
the area
where the development took place
thank you so that um it will depend very
much on the terms of the wireless
experience itself
um with regards to when we spend it we
have
um usually most 106's have a
um five-year payback clause in it
um so for example if a contribution
for a play area uh or upgrade to a play
area
is um required to be submitted prior to
occupation
we get the money in it's flagged up by
the finance team we then look to action
with the
open spaces team they potentially make
excuse me need to
go out for tender for contractors
full of work depending on the amount um
and the aim would be
that we've effectively spent that money
well within
two years and the work has occurred
within two years of actually getting it
um we have it for five years until
usually we have to either pay it back
but with certain agreements we don't
have to pay it back if we hold on to
money for more than
i'm i'm going to say i i believe it is
around
something like 12 years then for
different legal reasons we don't have to
pay it back
but obviously that is never the aim of
the council to hold on to money that we
could be spending on
on improvements as we look to do it as
well as quickly as we can really
yeah if it was identified for a
particular site
um who would counsellors chase up
for that particular uh money that that
would be me
councillor curry
email to follow
uh thank you chair um i know it's been
said but
um well done to the team who with the
recommendations and
um obviously as chair of planning i do
pick up
when i speak to miss simonson over there
about
the situation uh which i think most of
us know about
staffing in planning um
and what is being suggested about uh
ian's contribution to the whole um
review on a deadline set i i think that
is good um
i think most of us have seen as i put
the other
bit of chair and wave i think most of us
have seen you get
um it's like litter the joe public out
there they see something
and um of course it's sanic district
council's thought that it hasn't been
done
but they don't know the background
whether that is a building that looks
ugly or
it's going to be pulled down and so on
um
but so i only came into this on um
shooting in may but reading and
following it through
um the way it's going forward i must
admit um
i think it's very good thank you
members any other questions or comments
i've just got a uh
with a with an eye on the idea of
uh the planning enforcement portal and
the council's website
uh mr livingston and basically
looking at ways to inform the public
more frequently
and better there are a couple
of long-standing planning applications
uh
that have generated a fair amount of
public concern
one of them is of course the uh
for the benefit of the recording its uh
number is fth
20 1067 the newlands
piggery which is where there are
uh a number of traveler caravans
cited whilst they await a retrospective
planning
application and the other two are on
hope's lane
the presence of a burger bar on a
storage and distribution center and a
nail bar
both of which have generated an
extraordinary amount of traffic
um on a blind corner and so i get
a lot of contact via phone
and email from residents over these
uh matters and i know a lot of residents
actually contact the council directly
because i've been on the
uh the web page in the last few days
just to check
and every time a member of the public
writes in it appears up on there and
they do
draw some some applications not just the
big ones
but some of the little ones do tend to
draw a lot of public reactions so
with that in mind in terms of how best
to inform the the public
uh you know how we can inform them
better have you got a personal
idea of how that might work and uh if i
can be really cheeky
are there any updates on those two that
you are prepared to share
um so in terms of the um
the update with regards to how how it
would work
the the way that we um currently publish
planning applications
um has the ability to do the same sort
of principle with enforcement cases
um by potentially purchasing another
module
uh to go with our database it would
allow us to
publicize um or put on the website about
enforcement cases which means obviously
before making a complaint
someone could type the address in and
see whether someone's already made that
complaint
and to what you know to end um obviously
the key thing with regards to
enforcement is the information on the
complainants are kept confidential so we
would be locking down
how much information we would publish
but the aim would be through the review
is
to to find out what uh you know what
sort of sort of
update information can we provide via
those means
to um you know to get that information
out there um
just to touch on the the general issue
with regards to
um retrospective applications with
regards to
in relation to the cases that you've
mentioned um
often we will hold enforcement action
and balance until a retrospective
application
is determined now what the the aim is
always to make sure that
um we try and deal with retrospective
applications as quickly as possible
the reason why we hold action in
obeyance is because one
if it's granted by officers or indeed
members
then obviously we don't want to have
taken enforcement action which would
then have to
go back on but also because when serving
an enforcement notice
there is the right of appeal and if the
application's already been determined
for that
you know we don't have to defend quite
the same amount of or put in the same
amount of work so it speeds up the
process
at the end of the process after the
enforcement notice has been
served and in terms of those particular
cases
they are ongoing and enforcement are
aware
thank you very much
any further comments members um you have
the
full recommendations uh we have them
before us can i just because it doesn't
actually say so on here
can i just point out that any these
recommendations
or any others that you would like to
make we are recommending them to
cabinet not to counsel okay so they
would go
back to cabinet
um
so how do we feel about the four
recommendations that we have
our members happy to send those forward
as they've been presented to us thank
you councillor moore for the work that
you did
and the committee that worked to put
this together are there any changes that
members might like to make to those
comments so can i have your approval
then to
accept those recommendations and move
them on
can we have a proposal for the record i
propose actually councillor paul moore
thank you very much in a second there
councillor phil fellows
thank you very much
and members agree thank you very much
[Music]
a review of the overview and scrutiny
work panel um you will have already
picked up on the suggestion then that i
don't know whether you
have the chart in front of you that
we could be looking at a report back
from the planning enforcement review
on the 23rd of november
do members have any suggestions
for cabinet member presentations
and at this point i'd just like to drop
the idea of
inviting the new leader of the council
with the new administration
to come to this committee on the 26th
of august which is our next scheduled
meeting to give us an update
on how she and her cabinet and the
administration
uh plan to deal with certain issues that
she has
and particularly those that might of
course involve involve
us so would members be happy for me to
do that to invite the leader
to come on the 26th of august
okay thank you um
could we write to the leader an inviter
do i
write and send that
if you would please thank you very much
uh the meeting after that will be the
26th of october do members at this point
have anything they'd like to suggest
for that review council boyd
thank you chair i don't know which
meeting um this would be suitable for
and obviously we're asked to suggest
some out of the
table that we've got um may i make the
suggestion that the
private rented sector and how does tdc
regulate private landlords and letting
agencies and planets be added
particularly because with the end to
furlough
um and the end to you know you can't
kick people out because of the
pandemic and stuff like that so i think
now is possibly quite a tricky time
but would be good to see what we can
what the learnings are from
how we deal with the current situations
for the future
and to keep our residents safe obviously
i think that would be very timely yes
i'm sure other members agree that would
be very timely to to
um possibly the 26th of october then
just for interest please would we write
to bob porter about that or to hit the
officer
below him who actually deals with the
private rental sector
and and obviously bob will then engage
the portfolio holder because the
presentation will be
by the portfolio jointly with that
reporter
thank you
any other suggestions or comments
members counsel austin
i notice that the first two in priority
uh or on this list are um
are both about uh waste litter
um waste clearance etcetera and i wonder
if perhaps
uh council baby could be invited to to
speak around those topics
all right if we're following the uh
diary schedule that would be in january
can i just
join if i just make a point please yeah
so um
whilst i appreciate that members are
keen to get uh
cabinet members and officers along the
planet which is great
um you just need to bear in mind that we
are taking
items from the suggested scrutiny review
topics
and asking for presentations on them
instead of doing reviews
so we're confusing matters are we by
doing that you are potentially confusing
matters
um not that that's wrong there's nothing
wrong with that um and it's good to get
members to come along but
if you're going to invite a portfolio
holder to come along and talk about that
issue
then that's going to reduce the
importance of having a review on that
issue
at the same time so so if you want to do
a review
that's fine we can start organizing a
review or start putting that into
into train if you want us to or you can
invite
a portfolio holder along to to do that
um
so that's just to bear that in mind
because obviously we are now
i'm trying to think off top of my head
we've done the plan enforcement review
so that's finished
so that's okay for the time being the
memorials one is in a balance until the
government
decide to work out what it is they're
going to do
so there is a current vacancy for
for doing a review in that case can i
propose a waste management review that
picks up those
top two topics and as we were saying
immediately before the meeting among
several of us are
unrated of our case with as well
sorry i keep forgetting the microphone
okay we'll set that in motion
and we'll get a report for the sort of
terms of reference and what we're going
to do
at the next meeting which will enable
the review then to take place thank you
for that
council austin waste management review
any other comments members please
okay then members i uh
ask you then if we could all note that
report
we're also asked to note the report on
the forward plan exempt cabinet report
list
unless there are comments that members
wish to make
okay thank you very much in that case at
1936 that concludes the business
for tonight's meeting thank you very
much for coming and sharing
[Music]
i miss that sorry i thought somebody
asked me a question